dear boss I keep hearing the police have
called me but they won't fix me just yet
[Music]
Batman Gotham by Gaslight I debated
whether or not to keep this going but I
went through the trouble to bust it out
I'm gonna wear it for the whole review
so this is the latest animated film to
be done by DC and whereas once upon a
time I used to be able to count on these
for a minimum level of pretty good right
up to excellent these days there are
output has been let's be generous and
say inconsistent I haven't really been
following the reactions to this one
particularly because I mean I I found
myself more and more when there's
something that I know I'm going to see
regardless of what the responses that I
try and avoid finding out what that
response is because they don't want it
to taint my opinion as much as possible
and I've been doing that with these
movies for for a while now and I got
nervous right when it started up and the
thing came up saying rated R and like oh
god because I remember the last time
they did a rated R 1 which was the
killing joke and it's rated R in the
most superficial way that didn't really
need to be there I mean it's a little
bloody it's a little boring
it's like a couple of swears I'm kind of
inclined to say if they wanted to go for
the more like you know penny horror kind
of feel to it they should have dug in a
bit more and if they weren't gonna go
for that they should have used back from
a Fiat a pg-13 but whatever that's net
picking so Gotham by Gaslight is an
adaptation of what is generally
considered to be the first proper
Elseworlds story from DC where they take
characters as we know the main the main
DC continuity put them in a completely
different setting and basically see how
that shakes out so it's basically
creating a torreón era Gotham that is
being terrorized by Jack the Ripper and
Batman has to take him down so it pretty
much is that it's not a direct
adaptation in turn in terms of plot
point for plot point but it's the exact
same set up I'm in dealing with most of
the same characters a few things are
changing
now I haven't actually read Gotham by
Gaslight by I'm familiar with it I I've
seen excerpts from it I know the art
style I know how the story goes
so I can't at least make some of those
comparisons although I can't speak to
how good or not good the original was
because I don't actually know but
overall this movie isn't bad but
honestly it was kind of bored I think
there's a couple of things that are
contributing to that I think the first
thing is the the budget cuts that have
been hitting these animated movies I
think are becoming more and more and
more evident the animation is getting
really jerky and really under detailed
like to the point that it's kind of even
below the original animated series at
this point and it's yeah it's becoming
noticeable now they they they do the
smart thing and they up the quality of
the animation for the scenes that
desperately need it the most which is
usually the action scenes because if
those are jerky then you're really
screwed so you know they they keep it
decent through those but when it's
dialogue scenes boy the the mouth
movements are really choppy it's it's
just and it's not bad art the art is
pretty good like I said a little under
detailed I feel at times but it works it
sells what it's doing it's just it's
just the quality of the movement it
feels like it's getting a little bit
worse with every film and I don't
necessarily want to hold that against
the filmmakers cuz I do think that they
just keep cutting the budget on these
things so but you know I'd be remiss if
I didn't point that out the voice acting
here is all good which is nice because
that also used to be incredibly
dependable with these movies and it
isn't always anymore but they get Bruce
Greenwood back to do Batman he did
Batman for under the Red Hood so he
knows what he's doing he's quite good at
it the heavy Jennifer Carpenter is
Selina Kyle which is not a casting I
would have thought to do but she works
she worked quite well and everybody
else's is decent I mean they they're
they're the highlights they're the ones
who get the most central focus you know
but I mentioned just being kind of bored
and I think some of the other
contributors to that are
you know what for me part of the fun of
an Elseworlds is seeing how things are
different you know not just visually
aesthetically I mean this was a big part
of what I really loved about say gods
and monsters and it's part of what makes
red Sun so good which I think they are
doing an adaptation of we'll see how
that turns out but it's not just that
we're taking these characters putting
them in a different setting and letting
basically the same relationships play
out we're taking these characters
putting them in a different setting and
seeing how that changes them how it
alters the way that they behave how it
alters the way that they interact and
feel about each other and there isn't a
lot of that here I think you know and
I'm this isn't something I would hold
against the original source material
because like I said it was the first
proper Elseworlds but there's something
kind of a little disappointing about
going oh okay so Selina is not that far
off from what she always is and her
relationship with Batman is basically
the same and Batman is basically the
same and there's his relationship with
Gordon and all right Harvey done still
the district attorney and you're like
you're just going down the list and oh
okay there's Bullock and everyone is
poor is either precisely where they are
in the main continuity or close enough
that there's nothing particularly
surprising about it
so that was that that's a little
disappointing I think visually I'd also
kind of hoped it had been a bit more I
guess steampunk for lack of a better
term because that that's another sort of
thing like oh we're just going straight
Victorian we'll just find and and again
I'd I feel bad
complaining about that because that
becomes an issue of what I hoped to get
versus you know judging what I actually
got but like I said the whole thing
plays if you've seen any kind of hunt
Jack the Ripper story whether it's this
whether it's from hell whether it's
murder by decree you know whatever it
might be you've kind of seen a version
of this and this doesn't do a heck of a
lot to distinguish it from those and the
and oddly the inclusion of Batman
doesn't do much to distinguish from any
other we got to find Jack the Ripper
story they basically just says Batman
instead of whoever the heck the main
detective of any other story is he the
these battement doesn't play into this
very much at all really he's because he
kind of seems to already have the
standard Batman relationship with this
city and its residents and its major
players so I'm gonna have to get into a
little bit into spoilers to get it some
of the stuff that that bothered me a bit
more and also one of the moments some of
the moments that I liked so my overall
thing is it's not bad
I was bored through most of it I I think
just because of how few surprises it had
for me and I don't think that's strictly
speaking because it's an adaptation I
and I kind of know the source material
because they did alter enough of the
plot points that it it could have been
more surprising and and I again I can't
explain that without getting into
spoilers so some of the stuff that is
good we're now hitting spoilers so they
change who the killer is who Jack the
Ripper is from the original graphic
novel version which was a good call
because I don't want to spoil that one
but that was that was kind of a lame
situation there in this case in this
movie again spoilers here we go so it's
James Gordon and so he's doing this
basically because he can't he feels like
he can't clean up Gotham in his normal
capacity so he's going the extra mile so
to speak and that's not a bad angle
because usually when you're dealing with
Jack the Ripper you're gonna have a
twisted logic behind what they're doing
and that's suitably twisted so I think
having it be Jim Gordon was that was a
good call I props to them for that
execution falls apart a little bit
though because they have him do
something which is something that I hate
it happens a lot with sort of surprise
villains ie we know someone's bad guy oh
it turns out to be this guy we trusted
and what happens to off and it happens
here is the instant the audience becomes
aware that they are the killer they
start behaving in a way that is
completely different from how we've seen
them behave and I mean not just how
we've seen the character you know
undercover behave but how we've seen the
killer behave because we've seen a fair
amount of jack we see him skulking the
shadows pulls out the blade he
Hills women he is silent he doesn't talk
once he has revealed himself to Selena
Kyle as being Jack the Ripper instead of
immediately slitting her throat he
shrugs her which is not something we've
seen him do with any of the other women
he doesn't just go in for the kill
he starts monologuing all over the place
which is kind of lame in and of itself
but his extra lame here because he's
been silent this whole time and that
just drives me crazy that to have a
character because you've suddenly gone
oh we pulled the rug out from under the
audience and they use that as an excuse
to get away with completely altering
their behavior in a way that is
inconsistent with any version of this
character you know hidden villain or you
know it's suppose a friend that we've
seen up to this point and I hate that
it's lazy writing so they took something
that was a good idea in terms of who it
was gonna be and then botched the
execution Selena like I said does work
and actually she has some of the better
moments as well in terms especially in
terms of her interactions with Bruce I'm
actually kind of say Bruce cuz I feel
like we get more Bruce Wayne than we get
a Batman in this particular movie if I'm
being honest but like I really love the
moment where Bruce is in jail he has
been jailed and he's gonna be put on
trial for the repper martyrs and she
goes to him and at that point she
everybody knows he's Batman and she says
you have an ironclad alibi because they
know Batman was off somewhere else when
one of these killings happen but Bruce
won't admit to that he won't tell Guren
that he's Batman and she says I will
because I'm not gonna let more women die
just to keep your secret and that's
awesome that is that is a good thing for
her to do and it's not necessarily
inconsistent with how she's normally
portrayed in the comics but it's it's a
much stronger stance from her it's much
less conflicted as she's very certain
that this is the right thing to do and I
was I didn't necessarily see that coming
I thought that was really good and
overall like their chemistry is really
good that's probably the highlight of
the of the movie overall the action
scenes are pretty good but I mean
they're they're unremarkable they're
what I tend to complain about to a
certain extent one day when we have the
the more grounded action scenes in these
animated films which is that you know
I'm watching a couple of guys throw
throw punches at each other and it's not
that it's bad but I mean
it's animation you're not you're not
restricted by the limits of what a
stuntman can physically pull off so it's
always kind of disappointing for me when
it just comes down to throwing punches
back and forth but otherwise you know
the actions fine and the look of it like
I said unfortunately animation is is not
great some of the plot points are decent
not amazing and you know that there's
there's there's the various you know
normal characters sprinkled throughout
some work better than other if Hugo
Strange felt a little forced Tim Drake
Jason Todd and Dick Grayson actually
they were kind of they were kind of cool
I liked where they fit in but overall
like I said I just came away from this
it's by no means as bad as some of these
have been lately it is not as bad as you
know son of Batman or Batman versus
Robin or or Batman and Harley Quinn got
the Batman once it'd been on a real not
great street clearly but it's certainly
not as bad as any of those but like I
said it is just kind of dull it's it's
not there unless you really excessively
love the premise which admittedly it is
a cool premise especially if you haven't
read the original comic then I suspect
that you'll probably have some fun with
this but it doesn't it doesn't feel like
it does much more than present what you
would expect out of the premise Batman
versus Jack the Ripper in a Victorian
setting it pretty much is just that and
it's fine I won't ever watch it again so
those are my thoughts on Gotham by
Gaslight have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's all that
stuff that you can do you know support
me on patreon follow me on Twitter I got
podcast blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah links for all that stuff is down in
the description and as for me I'll be
back as soon as I can get my next fix
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]